[Music]  we are here at the world chess Hall of  Fame to honor the Caixa Club the  high-level donors who have given so  generously to the club over the years  [Music]  there are so many or amazing  organizations in st. Louis so it's  really complete to see all of you give  your time commitment to the thing was  just love and there are some small  things I'd like to turn it over to our  founder dr single thank you very much  and thank all of you for being here your  support makes a lot of our programming  just impossible especially our program  in 140 schools to our some elastic  coverage throughout the city Habib lost  a contest today he has to be my partner  in defense  [Music]  [Applause]